joining us now is the former number 10
spin doctor alastair campbell hello to
mr campbell thanks for joining us on the
program this morning chatting to nadine
zaha with a new chancellor this morning
and he said whichever party that you
represented he would absolutely want to
be on the polar opposite what would you
say in response to him
well i thought it was frankly weird he
he gets appointed to be chancellor the
exchequer
he could talk about any of the myriad
challenges facing the country his top
line seemed to be that bloku left
downing street 19 years ago
is the person behind this downfall of
boris johnson the person behind the
downfall of boris johnson is alexander
boris depel johnson he is the master of
his own downfall
kept afloat by ministers like zahaway
kept afloat by much of the right-wing
media but we now see i think the country
is ahead of these politicians the
country sees that boris johnson as i
said to you the last time i was on your
program
is a liar he's a crook he is incapable
of delivering proper leadership for this
country and the sooner that he's gone
the better
uh yeah but he might not go um
he might not
he he might not and you know two
ministers two cabinet ministers resigned
yesterday as i said to you before
three quarters of his mps minimum
because that's the ones who voted three
quarters of his back benches do not have
confidence in him we now see that there
are some members of the cabinet who've
gone other members of the cabinet who
are clearly thinking about it and yes he
may stay because the thing people need
to understand about boris johnson we're
not talking about a normal politician
we're not talking about a normal human
being we're talking about somebody who
has literally no shame he has no moral
compass whatsoever he has no commitment
to public office and the standards that
are meant to go with public office he's
concerned 100 purely about his own power
and his own survival he is the worst
possible person to be prime minister of
our country at this time and the only
people right now who can get rid of him
are those people that you're seeing on
your screens now and for zahawi
who parades around the place as being a
man of integrity to go on your program
this morning and say that boris johnson
is honest that makes him a liar as well
and i'll tell something else to mr
zahaway he's been education minister and
he had a nice easy ride as the vaccines
minister because she had some wonderful
people at oxford university doing the
hard work lifting for him he's now
chancellor the exchequer in charge of
the nation's finances he better
understand that people rightly are going
to come after him over his finances over
his business interest over the way he
has done business down the years and i
look forward to seeing how that unfolds
we hear what you're saying about the
prime minister but as you said we looked
at the cabinet which was earlier on this
week and he has the support of um apart
from two of them all of those people
around that table they've all tweeted
their support um he's got prime
minister's questions today he's then got
the liaison committee at three o'clock
this afternoon and he it's going to be a
bruising few days for him but he's still
in post as i said and if he limps
towards the end of uh this session of
parliament he's got the summer to
reflect regroup and then away he goes
again
well that and it means meantime k how
much damage gets done to the country how
much damage gets done to the economy how
much damage gets done to our standing in
the world we're seen as a global joke at
the moment i've been doing interviews
with mate radio and television in
different parts of the world they think
we are a global joke they think johnson
is a global joke and yes he's got the
cabinet support but you've just had an
interview there with david gork i do the
podcast every week with rory stewart
we've done a special episode today about
what's going on now
there are very good people in the
conservative party they're not in the
cabinet why are they not in the cabinet
because boris johnson has deliberately
surrounded himself with third-rate and
fourth-rate people who frankly would not
have got a job in the cabinet of any
other prime minister in history nadine
dorris dominic raab preeti patel they
wouldn't have got a job carrying
margaret thatcher's handbag they
wouldn't have got a job polishing john
major's shoes these are second-rate
third-rate people with a fifth-rate
prime minister and i think the country
now knows that they are the only people
propping him up and the sooner they find
a spine or find a soul or find a bit of
moral conscience and get rid of that
lying crooked charlatan who sits at that
cabinet table and disgraces this country
and disgraces downing street and
disgraces every principle that most
people in public office aspire to then
the better this country will be
um what you said that they're not in in
that cabinet because boris johnson
doesn't want them um
they're not up to scratch but i mean
boris johnson decided that they weren't
up to scratch didn't he and he is the
prime minister and he's one of the most
successful uh prime ministers um of this
century
sorry did you just say boris johnson is
one of the most successful prime
ministers of this century i did
based upon what he has achieved his
majority nothing here
i know you've got to sort of play
devil's advocate a bit he beat jeremy
corbyn in a general election he told a
pack of lies to win a election about his
oven ready brexit deal he has achieved
literally nothing our economy is going
backwards the kovid vaccine rollout that
he claims credit for as i know from
people oxford unity university was done
despite the government rather than
because of it he parades as a global
leader on ukraine which he uses only for
his own survival we are a mess as a
country his brexit is one flagship thing
he's going disastrously wrong honestly
kay you've got credibility for heaven's
sake for you to say boris johnson one of
the greatest prime ministers of this
sense i didn't say that the most
successful is what i said i said the
most successful and i was talking about
at the polls who else has a bigger
majority than him at the polls this
century
uh
tony blair in 1997
this century okay all right okay well we
haven't had that many prime ministers
this century and those that we've had
haven't done terribly well not least
david cameron who gave us the wretched
referendum and poor theresa may who got
ripped apart over it
this guy this guy is the worst prime
minister this country has ever had yes
he won a general election but let me
just remind you it was about half the
majority we got in 1997 but honestly the
guy is a liar he's a crook he's a
charlatan you know that i know that
everybody in the country knows that the
only people refusing to face up to that
fact are the people sitting at that
cabinet table javid and sunak belatedly
having defended the indefensible for far
too long they finally realized that
their reputation their credibility can
only be rescued by doing what they did
yesterday every single one of them
michael go where the hell is michael go
michael gobe is meant to be the brainy
guy in the cabinet what is he doing
sitting there knowing that he's enabling
and allowing this liar and this crook to
carry on another day in office every
single day that this guy's prime
minister this country gets trashed
further our reputation in the world gets
trashed further and these now are the
only people who can get rid of him and
so mr zahaway it's very nice to be
living rent-free inside your head but i
for one will keep going on about how
wretched and awful you people are in
propping this guy up because ultimately
you are the ones who've got to get him
to go and until you do that unless and
until you do that you are going to go
down in history as very minor
insignificant figures of ignominy who
have propped up a crook a liar and a
charlatan his prime minister of one of
the great countries of the world
i wish you wouldn't sit on the fence
alastair it's good to talk to you as
always thanks very much for joining us
thank you